This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. 30 days have September, April, June and November. February has 28 alone. All the rest have 31. Except in Leapier, that's the time when February's days are 29. That doesn't even rhyme. Oh, the poem I grew up with was slightly different. Producer Avery Truffleman. 30 days, half September, April, June, and November, all the rest have 31, except for February, which has 28 days clear and 29 in each leap year. Okay, I think that rhymes actually worse. Both poems say the same thing, which is that months don't make any logical sense.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。九月三十，四六冬（十一月），二月平年二十八，其余各月三十一。闰年二月二十九，这根本就不押韵。哦，我从小背的那个童谣稍微有点不同。制作人埃弗里·特拉夫尔曼。三十天，半个九月，四六冬，其余各月三十一，除了二月有整整二十八天，每个闰年二十九天。好吧，我觉得这其实更不押韵。两首童谣说的都是同一件事，那就是月份在逻辑上根本说不通。
A month is hardly a unit of measurement. It can be anywhere from 28 to 31 days. Sometimes it's four weeks. Sometimes five. Sometimes six. You have to buy a new calendar with new dates every single year. It's a strange design. Well, the year that we now have, and basically consider
月份很难算作一个计量单位。它可以是28天到31天之间的任意天数。有时是四周。有时五周。有时六周。你每年都得买一本印有新日期的新日历。这是一种奇特的设定。嗯，我们现在拥有并基本上认为
almost a writ of God, you know, somehow it's just indivisible. There it is. Actually, it's had an amazing history. That is David Ewing Duncan. And I am the author of Calendar. Humanities epic struggle to determine a true and accurate year. The calendar that the world really uses right now is mostly a sort of joining of the Roman calendar and Egyptian calendar. It's basically when Caesar and Cleopatra were kind of hanging out and doing their thing. Which is to say, when Roman Caesar and Egyptian Cleopatra were having a Torrid love affair. This was before Cleopatra got together with Mark Antony. She was 21 and Caesar was 52. But they got together and they did what lovers do.
简直是上帝的旨意，你知道的，不知怎么的它就是不可分割的。事实就是如此。实际上，它的历史非常精彩。那是大卫·尤因·邓肯。我是《日历》一书的作者。人类为了确定真实而准确的年份所进行的史诗般的奋斗。现在全世界真正使用的日历，基本上是由罗马历和埃及历融合而成的。这基本上是凯撒和克利奥帕特拉在一起厮混并做他们那些事的时候。也就是说，当罗马的凯撒和埃及的克利奥帕特拉陷入热恋的时候。这发生在克利奥帕特拉和马克·安东尼在一起之前。她21岁，凯撒52岁。但他们走到了一起，做着恋人们会做的事。
Discussed the true nature of the Earth's rotation. And the Egyptians long before the Greeks came, actually discovered the true length of the year. 365 days. And the Egyptians knew about the length of the year because of the Nile River. They had something called a Nile meter. It was basically a series of steps that went into the Nile River. They had something called a Nileometer. It was basically a series of steps that went into the Nile.
讨论地球自转的真实本质。早在希腊人到来之前很久，埃及人就实际发现了年份的真正长度。365天。埃及人之所以知道年份的长度，是因为尼罗河。他们有一种叫做尼罗河计的东西。它基本上是一系列延伸到尼罗河里的台阶。他们有一种叫做尼罗米特的东西。它基本上是一系列延伸到尼罗河里的台阶。
The Nile actually flooded at the same height, virtually every year, on the same day. And they were just simply marked each year when it hit its height. But the Egyptians also figured out that the year isn't always exactly 365 days, so they added an extra day every four years, just to make sure that the calendar matched up with the seasons. In other words, they invented the leap year. And this was all fantastic news to Caesar, because he had a feeling that the Roman calendar wasn't quite right.
尼罗河实际上几乎每年都在同一天涨到相同的高度。他们只是简单地在每年水位达到最高时做上标记。但埃及人也发现，年份并不总是正好是365天，所以他们每四年增加一个闰日，只是为了确保日历与季节保持一致。换句话说，他们发明了闰年。对凯撒来说，这绝对是个大好消息，因为他觉得罗马历不太对劲。
The Roman calendar year, at the time, was around 354 days long. Obviously, that's a few days short, right? 11 days about short from the actual solar year. And when you lose 11 days, year after year after year, the seasons start to drift. They're spring and the winter months, winter and the fall months. And those 11 days were missing
当时的罗马历一年大约是354天。显然，这少了好几天，对吧？比实际的太阳年大约少11天。当你年复一年地损失这11天时，季节就开始发生偏移。春天和冬天，冬天和秋天。那11天不见了
because the Roman calendar had always been based on moon cycles. Cleopatra inspired Caesar to switch to a calendar that would be consistent with the Earth's cycle around the Sun. When Caesar returned to Rome from his dalliance with Cleopatra, he introduced the leap year, which is called the Julian calendar. Julius Caesar also added back those 11 missing days. And the Julian calendar was instituted throughout the Roman Empire, which is to say,
因为罗马历一直是以月相周期为基础的。克利奥帕特拉启发凯撒改用一种与地球绕太阳公转周期相一致的历法。凯撒结束了与克利奥帕特拉的恋情回到罗马后，引入了闰年，被称为儒略历。尤里乌斯·凯撒还加回了那缺失的11天。儒略历在整个罗马帝国推行，也就是说，
throughout much of the world. But it was still a bit off. The Julian calendar wasn't entirely accurate itself. It was about 11 minutes, 14 seconds off each year. Eventually you had, you were losing days, and then there was a week, and by 1582, Pope Gregory the 13th had to wear a thought to say, okay, we are actually, we have an inaccurate calendar we're worshiping all of our holy days on the wrong day from what they originally were. And with a few small adjustments to realign the year with the seasons, we have the Gregorian calendar named after Pope Gregory.
在世界大部分地区推行。但它仍然有点偏差。儒略历本身并不完全准确。每年大约有11分钟14秒的误差。最终你会发现，你在不断失去天数，然后是一周，到了1582年，教皇格里高利十三世不得不站出来说，好吧，实际上，我们一直在使用一张不准确的历法，我们所有的节日都在错误的日子庆祝，而不是它们原本的日子。通过对历法进行一些小调整，使年份与季节重新对齐，我们便有了以教皇格里高利命名的格里高利历。
And that's what's on your wall or your phone. We all use it, we don't think about it now. And for that reason, there has not been a huge momentum to try to change things. I mean, we basically live with it. But there are a lot of smart people out there, have been for centuries, that have come up with better calendars, and there are better calendars. One example of calendar redesign came after the French Revolution.
这就是挂在你墙上或手机里的历法。我们都在使用它，现在也不会去多想。正因如此，人们并没有想要去改变它的巨大动力。我的意思是，我们基本上就这么凑合着过日子。但是有很多聪明人，几个世纪以来一直如此，他们想出了更好的历法，而且确实存在更好的历法。日历重新设计的一个例子出现在法国大革命之后。
The French decreed the first year of the revolution was the year one, and they made the week 10 days long. This was actually instituted for over a decade. Then Napoleon put the Kabash on that when he became emperor. And later, another Frenchman created the so-called positivist calendar. The positivist calendar was created in 1849 by August Comte. He reorganized the months and renamed them after the great minds of history. Moses, Homer, Aristotle, Archimedes, Caesar, St. Paul. All the great white men of history.
法国人宣布大革命的第一年为元年，并将一周定为10天。这一制度实际上实行了十多年之久。后来拿破仑当上皇帝后，就把这事给叫停了。后来，另一个法国人创立了所谓的实证主义历法。实证主义历法是由奥古斯特·孔德于1849年创立的。他重新编排了月份，并用历史上的伟大智者的名字重新命名。摩西、荷马、亚里士多德、阿基米德、凯撒、圣保罗。所有历史上的伟大白人男性。
Charles Meng, Dante, Gutenberg, Shakespeare. That's Mark Burns, by the way. My name is Mark Burns. I am the visual editor for Cedilab. That positivist calendar didn't really take off. It was mostly meant as an inspirational memorial to glorify great thinkers. And, you know, patriarchy. However, there was another radical attempt at calendar reform that actually kind of happened.
查尔斯·芒格、但丁、古腾堡、莎士比亚。顺便说一句，那是马克·伯恩斯。我叫马克·伯恩斯。我是CityLab的视觉编辑。那个实证主义历法并没有真正流行起来。它主要被用作赞美伟大思想家的激励性纪念。而且，你知道的，还有父权制。然而，还有另一次激进的历法改革尝试，它确实在某种程度上发生了。
And Mark Burns wrote a piece about it for CityLab. I wrote The Death and Life of the Thirteen Month Calendar. This was a highly rational 13 month calendar meant to appeal not to romantics but to industrialists. Because the wonky, weirdly divided Gregorian calendar was difficult for accountants who had to track monthly numbers and for the people who had to make the trains run on time. And Moses B. Cotsworth was both of those people. trains run on time, and Moses B. Cotsworth was both of those people. Moses B. Cotsworth was an analytic sky mostly working in the railway industry. Cotsworth was a British railway man and he was all about efficiency.
马克·伯恩斯为此在CityLab上写了一篇文章。我写了《十三月历的生死》。这是一份高度理性的十三月历，旨在吸引的不是浪漫主义者，而是实业家。因为这个古怪的、划分奇怪的格里高利历对于必须追踪每月数字的会计师以及那些需要确保火车准点运行的人来说非常困难。而摩西·B·科茨沃思正是这两种人。火车准点运行，而摩西·B·科茨沃思正是这两种人。摩西·B·科茨沃思是一个主要在铁路行业工作的分析型人才。科茨沃思是一名英国铁路员工，他极其追求效率。
The Gregorian calendar wasn't cutting it for him. So let's say there's a month where there's an extra Monday or there's a month where there's an extra Saturday that would throw off the numbers from month to month. And that kind of frustrated Cotsworth. So he created his 13 month calendar. In 1902, Cotsworth presented a design for a calendar of 13 months, where every month was exactly 28 days. No more, no less.
格里高利历对他来说根本不够用。比方说，如果有一个月多出了一个星期一，或者有一个月多出了一个星期六，这就会打乱各个月份之间的数字。这让科茨沃思感到很沮丧。于是他创造了自己的十三月历。1902年，科茨沃思提出了一种13个月的日历设计，其中每个月正好是28天。不多不少。
Four perfect weeks. And this meant the dates were all standardized as well. You'd always know that the fifth was a Thursday, no matter the month. The first was always a Sunday, the tenth was always a Tuesday. There'd be a Friday, the thirteenth, every single month. Rational railway men were not superstitious, clearly. All the month names would stay the same, and then that additional month, another 28 even days, would fall between June and July, and this additional month would be called Seoul.
四个完美的星期。这意味着日历上的日期也都标准化了。无论哪个月，你总能知道初五是星期四。初一是星期天，初十是星期二。每个月的十三号都是星期五。理性的铁路工人显然一点也不迷信。所有的月份名称都保持不变，然后那个额外的月份——另外28个偶数天——将落在六月和七月之间，这个额外的月份将被命名为索尔（Seoul）。
S-O-L. Seoul, standing for the month where the summer solstice occurs. And the leap year day would be added at the end of Seoul, not February. So every four years Seoul would have 29 days. Alright, so 28 days times 13 months is 364 days in a year. That is one day less than the actual solar year of 365. So to make it 365, Cotsworth added a new holiday right before the new year. There's extra day at the end of the year, called Year Day.
S-O-L。索尔，代表夏至发生的月份。闰日将加在索尔的末尾，而不是二月。所以每四年索尔会有29天。好吧，28天乘以13个月等于一年有364天。这比365天的实际太阳年少一天。因此，为了凑够365天，科茨沃思在新年之前加入了一个新的节日。年终多出的一天，被称为“年日”（Year Day）。
And Year Day was just a floating day, not part of any particular month, and it would be a sort of global Sabbath. And aside from Year Day, all other vacations would be moved to a Monday. Holidays would always be practiced or observed on Mondays. You don't have to worry about certain months where everyone's out on a Wednesday, and maybe since they have Wednesday off, they want to schedule a Thursday and Friday off. None of that nonsense.
“年日”只是一个浮动的天数，不属于任何特定的月份，它将成为一种全球安息日。除了“年日”之外，所有其他假期都将移至星期一。假期将始终在星期一庆祝或度过。你不必担心某些月份大家都在星期三休息，而且也许因为他们星期三放假，他们还想顺便请假周四和周五。没有那种无稽之谈。
Holidays would all be three-day weekends. No Wednesdays off. Cotsworth pitched his perfect calendar around the United States, giving talks about its myriad benefits, but he couldn't find many takers. Except for one of the wealthiest and most successful businessmen of that time,
假期都将变成三天的小长假。没有周三休息这回事。科茨沃思在美国各地推销他完美的日历，举办讲座介绍其无数的好处，但他找不到太多买账的人。除了当时最富有、最成功的商人之一，
George Eastman. George Eastman, the founder of Kodak. Mr. Eastman had a lot of unique interests in addition to his company and his philanthropic work, but this I have to say is probably one of the weirdest interests that he had in pursuit. Kathy Connor is the curator of the George Eastman House and collection in Rochester, New York. When he had an interest in anything, he always put a decent amount of money into getting other people to buy into his ideas as well, and he did exactly that with the 13-month calendar.
乔治·伊士曼。乔治·伊士曼，柯达的创始人。除了他的公司和慈善工作之外，伊士曼先生还有很多独特的兴趣，但不得不说，这可能是他追求的最奇怪的兴趣之一。凯茜·康纳是纽约州罗切斯特市乔治·伊士曼故居及收藏馆的馆长。当他对某事感兴趣时，他总是会投入相当多的资金，让其他人也接受他的想法，他在十三月历上也正是这么做的。
Eastman basically took it upon himself to promote Cotsworth's calendar design, and he started a calendar league headquarters in Rochester Rochester in Codax office. He gave a little office to this calendar reform group and it was there that they published and printed some different flyers to hand out to local businesses. They actually convinced a few local businesses to switch to a 13 month calendar, including, of course, Mr. Eastman's own company. They adopted it at the Eastman Code Act Company in 1924, and they continued to use it until 1989, so they had a 65 years.
伊士曼基本上主动承担起了推广科茨沃思日历设计的任务，他在罗切斯特柯达办公室设立了一个日历联盟总部。他给这个历法改革小组提供了一间小办公室，正是在那里，他们出版并印刷了各种传单分发给当地企业。他们实际上说服了一些当地企业改用十三月历，其中当然包括伊士曼先生自己的公司。他们在1924年的伊士曼柯达公司采用了这种历法，并一直使用到1989年，所以他们使用了65年。
Let me just repeat that they used this calendar until 1989. Apparently employees found it useful. When I did sales reporting programs, I didn't have to worry about, well this is a 28-day month, this is a 31-day month, this is a 30-day month, I acclimated it very quickly. John Soraka worked at Kodak from 1986 to 1992, and he actually liked the calendar so much that he tried to bring it with him beyond Kodak. A couple of times I've actually tried getting companies that I've worked for to go and tried to bring it with him beyond Kodak. But like Moses' cutsworth in George Eastman before him, John Seraco just couldn't convince
请允许我再次重申，他们使用这个日历一直到了1989年。显然，员工们发现它很有用。当我做销售报告程序时，我不用担心，嗯，这是个28天的月份，这是个31天的月份，这是个30天的月份，我非常快就适应了。约翰·索拉卡于1986年至1992年在柯达工作，他实际上非常喜欢这个日历，以至于他试图把它带出柯达。我有好几次真的试图让我工作过别的公司也去——试图把它带出柯达。但就像他之前的摩西·科茨沃思和乔治·伊士曼一样，约翰·塞拉科就是无法说服
other businesses to take it on. That said, even within Kodak, Eastman couldn't fully institute the 13-month calendar in its truest form. The calendar, as John knew it, was kind of a modified version. I only knew it as this is the financial calendar of the Eastman Kodak company. Kodak employees didn't observe soul or year-day or change every holiday to a Monday. It was like how some bankers work in quarters or some schools function in semesters. Kodak's internal schedule was organized into 13 periods. Just called period 1 to period 13.
其他企业接受它。话虽如此，即使在柯达内部，伊士曼也无法完全以最真实的形式推行十三月历。在约翰看来，这个日历其实是一个修改版本。我只知道它是伊士曼柯达公司的财务日历。柯达员工并不庆祝索尔月或年日，也没有把所有假期都改到星期一。这就像有些银行家按季度工作，或者有些学校按学期运作一样。柯达内部的日程安排被组织成13个周期。只被称为第1周期到第13周期。
Instead of saying that today was March 6, we would say that today is the third period day three. They used the 13-month calendar as an organizational tool for planning finances and production schedules. We programmed and we wrote and we designed applications to work within the code at 13 periods, but we still lived our life the way the normal Gregorian calendar was. Because, of course course the rest of the world was still on the Gregorian calendar. Renaming and reorganizing the days and holidays would have been a total drag. And this is basically the same reason why it would be so hard for the larger world to adopt a 13 month calendar.
我们不会说今天是3月6日，而是会说今天是第三周期的第三天。他们将十三月历用作规划财务和生产计划的组织工具。我们编写、设计了应用程序来配合柯达的13个周期运作，但我们的日常生活依然按照正常的格里高利历进行。因为，当然，世界其他地方仍然在使用格里高利历。重新命名和重组日子与假期将是一件极其麻烦的事。这基本上也就是为什么更大的世界很难采用十三月历的同一个原因。
The explanation for how July 4th at work is kind of like the perfect example of how complicated it would be to mentally adjust to this new calendar. That's journalist Mark Burns again. Okay, so on the 13-month calendar schedule, July 4th would have to be moved to a Monday, like all the holidays. So then… It would really be July 2nd. But when you add in Seoul and shuffle the dates around accordingly, that actual day on the solar calendar wouldn't fall in July anymore.
关于7月4日在工作中是如何运作的解释，有点像是说明适应这种新日历在精神上会有多复杂的完美例子。那是记者马克·伯恩斯。好吧，在十三月历的日程安排下，7月4日必须像所有节日一样移到星期一。所以……那实际上会变成7月2日。但是，当你把索尔月加进来并相应地重新调整日期时，太阳历上的那一天将不再落在七月。
It would actually be Seoul 17, but that falls on a Tuesday. So again, you gotta make that a Monday, so it would end up as Seoul 16. So there's nothing as patriotic as celebrating Seoul 16. This is why the calendar and its truest most regulated form couldn't fully work at Kodak. I mean, you have to give your employees a vacation on July 4th, even if it's not on a Monday. So random holidays and off days persisted. George Eastman knew that if he wanted to standardize the calendar, Kodak couldn't do it alone. He would have to convince the rest of the world to make the switch.
它实际上会是索尔月17日，但那是一个星期二。所以同样地，你必须把它改成星期一，所以最终它会变成索尔月16日。所以没有什么比庆祝“索尔月16日”更爱国的事了。这就是为什么这种日历及其最真实、最规范的形式无法在柯达完全行得通的原因。我的意思是，你必须给你的员工在7月4日放假，即使它不在星期一。因此，随意的假期和休息日依然存在。乔治·伊士曼知道，如果他想让日历标准化，柯达单凭一己之力是做不到的。他必须说服世界其他地方做出改变。
He and Mr. Katzworth, they went to bat a few times in front of a lot of different committees at Congress and in our government to try to just explain the rationale. And this was taken completely seriously. Calendar reform became an actual issue of debate for the League of Nations. The League of Nations has in the precursor to the UN. There are 185 plans before the League of Nations to look at for calendar reform. And Cotsworth and Eastman's proposal
他和科茨沃思先生在国会和我们政府的许多不同委员会面前多次据理力争，试图解释其中的合理性。这得到了完全认真的对待。日历改革成为国际联盟辩论的实际议题。国际联盟是联合国的雏形。国际联盟有185个供审查的日历改革计划。而科茨沃思和伊士曼的提案
was one of the few finalists. Even after George Eastman passed away in 1932, the League of Nations continued discussing calendar redesign. Basically, League of Nations couldn't come to a consensus, and then the rise of Hitler and World War II made it thoroughly unimportant to them, and then the League of Nations folded. Hitler ruins everything, and we just haven't really considered calendar reform since. Perhaps because, when designing time and the way people operate, you have to consider custom and culture. It has to be done entirely and completely, or not at all.
是为数不多的几个决赛入围者之一。甚至在乔治·伊士曼于1932年去世后，国际联盟仍在继续讨论日历的重新设计。基本上，国际联盟无法达成共识，然后希特勒的崛起和第二次世界大战使得这件事对他们来说彻底变得不重要了，接着国际联盟就解散了。希特勒毁了一切，从那以后我们便再也没有真正考虑过日历改革。也许是因为，在设计时间和人们的运作方式时，你必须考虑习俗和文化。要么彻底而完整地完成，要么干脆不做。
So who knows, perhaps if everyone decided to adopt it, a regimented calendar could really work better for, you know, finances and planning. But on the other hand, I think it's kind of fascinating that our year is not perfectly regimented. It's out of our control. Sometimes your birthday is on a Tuesday. Sometimes it's a Saturday. The Gregorian calendar is this organic instrument that ebbs and flows with the seasons
所以谁知道呢，也许如果每个人都决定采用它，一个规整的日历确实能对财务和规划发挥更好的作用。但从另一方面来看，我觉得我们的年份并非完美规整，这其实挺迷人的。这是我们无法控制的。有时你的生日是星期二。有时是星期六。格里高利历是一个有机的工具，它随着季节的更替而起伏
on the rotation of the Earth. I've got to have spent too much time in California. It's really a bizarre anomaly of history that this calendar that started with a season of Cleopatra that was reformed by a pope. It was really a Christian calendar. It's now the calendar of the world. And all we have to help us remember it is a stupid rhyme. That doesn't even rhyme.
随着地球的自转。我肯定是在加州待了太久了。由克利奥帕特拉的一个赛季开始、由教皇进行改革的这个日历，真的是历史上的一个离奇异常。它其实是一个基督教日历。它现在是全世界的日历。而我们用来帮自己记住它的，只有一句蠢透了的童谣。这根本就不押韵。
By the way we talked to another long time Kodak employee for this story. Yes my name is Robert Sheenbrock. I was for Kodak for 35 years. Robert wrote a book about how Kodak film was made called Making Kodak Film. This manufacturing process used to be top secret, but Robert got insider access to Kodak's facilities. I spent 40 days photographing in the factory, like 165 photographs that show all the equipment and explains the process. This is like its own separate episode. Check it out, nerds. It's makingcodacfilm.com.
顺便说一句，我们在这个故事中采访了另一位柯达的老员工。是的，我叫罗伯特·希恩布罗克。我在柯达工作了35年。罗伯特写了一本关于柯达胶片是如何制造的书，名为《制作柯达胶片》。这个制造过程曾经是绝密，但罗伯特获得了进入柯达设施内部的特许。我在工厂里花了40天拍照，拍了大约165张照片，展示了所有的设备并解释了整个过程。这就像是一个独立的番外集。去看看吧，极客们。网址是makingcodacfilm.com。
99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Troubleman with Sam Greensppan, Katie Mingle, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm, where designing a new chicken waffles place in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. I'm so excited about the chicken waffles place. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio.
本周的《99%隐形》由埃弗里·特拉夫尔曼制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同参与。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作于建筑与室内设计公司ArcSign的办公室里，该公司目前正在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心设计一家新的炸鸡华夫饼店。我对这家炸鸡华夫饼店兴奋不已。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有节目，你必须访问 99pi.org。Radio Tapio。
From PRX. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。